The first of the three sensory systems with a specific sensory cortex is the
visual cortex, which is located in the occipital lobes. The second is the
auditory cortex, which is located in the temporal lobes. And the third is the
somatosensory cortex, which is responsible for touch and is located in the
parietal lobes. Our sense of smell and taste don't have their own processing
region. However, it's interesting to note that smell can bring forth very
strong and immediate memory. Have you, for example, noticed that particular
smells can bring back a memory for you? I can think of a few myself. For
example, the smell of homemade pizza reminds me of my grandmother. The smell of
the beach reminds me of the summers my family and I spent on the beach. Or, for
example, maybe the smell of a perfume or cologne reminds you of an ex-lover you
once had. That's just an example of how smells can evoke powerful memories.
Stop and think for a minute if you recall any particular smells that bring back
a memory to you.